Professor Charles
Bailyn: We were talking
about relativity.
And where we ended up last
time--we were talking about
special relativity and all the
weird things that happen to
space and time.
And the question arose,
you know, what prompted
Einstein to think these
thoughts?
And we talked a little bit
about the fact that the speed of
light is always the same no
matter what the velocity of the
person observing it and how
that--then,
if you take that literally,
it tells you that space and
time are weird,
and are not constant and
absolute the way you might think
they are in a Newtonian sense,
but vary according to the
velocity of the observer and in
these various ways having to do
with that parameter gamma.
And so, Einstein's great stroke
of genius was not to try and fix
up these little problems with
the experiment in some,
sort of, patchwork kind of way,
or to try and invoke a minor
change in the laws of nature,
but to recognize that this was
a very big deal,
and that would involve changing
fundamentally how we think space
and time work.
So, this is a very famous fable
of science, you know.
This is the thing where
Einstein is a young man,
and he's sort of a rebel.
And he refuses to take his exam
and he pisses off his
professors.
And the consequence is he
doesn't get a good job.
And he gets this job at the
patent office right,
in Bern, Switzerland,
where he labors away in
obscurity.
And then, suddenly,
in a blaze of glory in 1905,
he publishes three papers,
one of which is about
relativity,
one of which is the start of
quantum mechanics,
and the other of which proves
that atoms exist.
And so, these are three of the
greatest papers of all time,
published in a single year,
by some clown who's a clerk in
a patent office.
All right.
Very big deal.
This happened in 1905,
two years ago it was the
hundredth anniversary of this.
This was declared Einstein
Year, and all sorts of fuss was
made about it.
So, there are various morals
that can be drawn from this.
And I'm going to draw several
of them in what you might call
increasing order of
sophistication.
So, the low sophistication
moral, moral number one,
here, is, you know,
about the genius in obscurity.
A genius in obscurity can
revolutionize science.
This is a very dangerous way to
approach the Einstein story.
Because it--you know,
it's really easy to convince
yourself that you are a genius
in obscurity.
Many people have convinced
themselves that they are
geniuses in obscurity.
I know about this,
because they send me email.
And they explain to me in their
email that they send me--and
this happens to,
you know, any scientist,
particularly someone working in
astrophysics or fundamental
physics of some kind--they
explain to me why Einstein was
wrong.
And indeed, why all science
known to date is wrong,
and they are right.
And then, they say,
you know, nobody believed
Einstein either--as if that was
somehow meant to make you
believe them.
They tend to write these things
all in capital letters.
There's a kind of pathology.
When they used to write--when
they used to do it on pencil and
paper, they would write in such
a way that you--they covered
every inch of the paper.
And, you know,
they'd write something,
then they'd write around the
margins, back to the top.
There's some psychological
thing--I don't know what it is.
But the legend of Einstein
prompts a whole bunch of people
to think that they too might be
patent clerks.
Yes?
Student: How do people
find you?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
well, look.
You can look up the astronomy
department website of Harvard,
Yale and Princeton,
and you'll find a whole bunch
of people, I suppose.
I also have published papers on
black holes, and things that
made their way into the media.
I've actually had a fall-off on
this, because I haven't been,
you know, quoted opining about
black holes in The New York
Times recently.
But ten years ago that--well
I'll explain that in a couple
weeks.
There was an interesting thing
that happened.
In any case,
you know, if you want to
publicize your theory,
what you do is you find a bunch
of fairly prominent people in
the field and you send them a
big screen saying,
you know, you will regret it if
you do not appreciate my genius.
Student: Do you ever
read it?
Do you read them?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Sometimes I do.
We have a little file in the
library called the Crank File,
in the Astronomy Department
library.
And from time to time,
you know, we assign graduate
students to figure out why
they're wrong.
We haven't done that lately.
Sometimes people amuse
themselves by answering them.
This can get you into various
kinds of trouble.
There was the gentleman with
the theory of the Universe,
which he illustrated in colored
pencils,
while he was serving his time
at a medium security institution
in Washington State.
And we thought,
you know, what a great way
to--you know,
much better way to be spending
your time in prison than some
other things you could think of.
So, we sent him a bunch of
textbooks and stuff.
Then we started getting letters
back, saying,
after I finish my sentence,
I'm coming to study with you,
and explaining why he was
innocent of the crime of which
he had been committed.
And so, at a certain point we
started returning things,
you know.
No, terribly sorry,
this individual has left Yale.
We don't know where he is,
whoever it was.
This is Jerry Orosz who carried
on this conversation for a
while.
And so, you have to be a little
bit careful.
And then--oh there was the
guy--This was amazing.
There was a guy who showed up
at the start of the semester.
He's dressed in a suit and tie,
carrying a briefcase,
walks into the department
office and says,
"Where's my classroom?
I'm supposed to teach
cosmology."
And he looked very respectable.
The secretary thought,
not with us,
you're not, so sent him over to
the Physics Department.
He asked the same question of
He had just walked in off the
street with a briefcase full of
his textbook.
And he was very annoyed that we
hadn't assigned him a classroom
and assigned students to come
and learn, you know,
his particular theory of
cosmology.
And in the end,
he had to be escorted off the
premises, and asked never to
return.
So yeah, all kinds of patent
clerks in the world,
but most of them aren't
Einstein.
That's kind of the moral.
And the reason you can
tell--you asked whether I read
these things.
It's very easy to tell whether
there's anything that you might
be useful to read.
Because what these people tend
to say when they are not worth
reading is, they tend to say
that all previous science is
wrong.
I am revolutionizing things.
Einstein is wrong, they say.
But Einstein didn't say that
Newton was wrong.
That wasn't what happened.
That wasn't how a revolution
works.
You revolutionize science only
if the new theory encompasses
what was previously known--the
previous theories.
And this is this business of
the parameter,
gamma, where under appropriate
circumstances,
gamma is one.
And under those circumstances,
you reproduce the theory that
was already in existence.
And so, you know,
there's been hundreds and
hundreds of years of Newtonian
physics, all of which is
basically right,
one way or another.
So whatever your new idea is
has to encompass all the things
that were right about the old
idea.
And so, you don't overturn
Newton.
What you do is,
you demonstrate that Newton's
theory is only a part of a
bigger theory.
And then, the bigger theory is
the new theory and it
encompasses new kinds of data
and explains new kinds of
things,
while simultaneously not
overturning all the things that
you know are right about the old
theory.
And this is the thing that the
people who wish they were
Einstein, but aren't,
don't understand.
And so, anytime you see
something where you're--where
they're going to revolutionize
all of science,
it's certainly wrong.
Because there's a large
fraction of science in current
existence that is correct.
And you have to understand that.
And you have to encompass it
and go beyond that--but it's not
going to get overturned.
The planets aren't going to
stop going in Keplerian orbits
because somebody has a new idea.
And so, it has to encompass the
old idea.
Recently, in conjunction,
in part with Einstein Year,
two years ago,
the historians of science have
been rethinking what's going on
with Einstein,
and what happened in that
patent office.
And there's a new kind of idea
that actually,
it was--it wasn't that he was
working in obscurity and
some--and,
you know, flipping burgers or
something--that his work in the
patent office was very important
to the way he developed his
theory.
And that one of the reasons
Einstein did what he did was he
was working in a patent office
and not in a university.
Because, what was he doing in
the patent office?
Well, it turns out that in the
early part of the twentieth
century, one of the big set of
inventions that was coming
through were ways of
synchronizing clocks.
It turn--because railroads had
just been invented.
And until then,
you had had a situation where
every city had its own time.
Every city had a little
observatory.
They would figure out when the
Sun was directly overhead.
They would proclaim that to be
noon.
They'd fire off a whistle.
Everyone would set all their
clocks.
But that meant--but they didn't
have time zones.
And that meant that every
little town had a different time
system.
There was--Boston time was
different from Hartford time,
was different from New York
time by 22.5 minutes,
or whatever the appropriate
amount would be.
And that's all fine,
if you move between these
cities slowly.
If you start running trains,
you've got to have--the train
system has to have a unified
system of time,
otherwise they run into each
other.
And there were crashes and
terrible things.
And so, then,
you have to have--okay.
Then you have to have Boston
and New York having the same
time.
So, how do you synchronize
those clocks?
Well, you've just invented the
telegraph, so you send an--you
send an electromagnetic signal
at the speed of light from
Boston to New York,
and then back again,
in order to synchronize your
clocks.
And there were various
inventions that Einstein was
reviewing in the patent office
to accomplish this.
And so, in his job,
in his day job,
he spent all his time thinking
about clocks and time,
and signals moving at the speed
of light.
So, perhaps it isn't surprising
that he had deep insights into
these kinds of things.
So, the current feeling among,
at least, some historians of
science, is that the patent
office was, in fact,
key to Einstein's thinking.
So, he didn't come out of
obscurity at all.
He came out of the only place
where the surroundings were such
that you would have thought
these thoughts.
This is associated with a
historian of science named Peter
Galison, among others,
who wrote a book called
Einstein's Clocks and
Poincare's Maps to try and
demonstrate how the practical
work these people were doing
influenced their theoretical
work.
Yes?
Student: Was it
triggered by one event?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well no,
he--was he triggered by one
particular event?
What prompted him to think
about this was a whole series of
experiments that had been
carried out--all of which,
as I mentioned last time,
one way or another,
demonstrated that this business
that the speed of light was
constant in all reference
frames.
And that there was no ether
through which was the medium
that was imagined to exist
through which electromagnetic
waves were supposed to pass.
And there had been a series of
experiments to try and detect
slight changes in the speed of
light when you put it on a
rail--when you put it on a
train, right?
It's all about trains and
elevators, which had just been
invented.
And--but it wasn't one
particular triggering event.
There was this whole range of
things.
And Einstein,
it should be said,
was, by far,
not the only person thinking
about this.
We call the transformations
Lorentz transformations,
because there was a guy named
Lorentz who thought them up.
Mathematicians like Poincare,
physicists like
Minkowski--there were a whole
bunch of people thinking about
this,
and it was an urgent problem in
physics.
And so that had to be dealt
with.
And if Einstein hadn't existed,
it might have taken a little
longer, but we would have gotten
special relativity in the end.
That's not necessarily true of
general relativity,
as I'll explain in a second.
General relativity--if Einstein
hadn't existed,
general relativity might not
have happened until the 1960s,
because it was not prompted by
a range of experimental results.
The other bunch of experimental
results that were prominent at
the time were the atomic physics
experiments that lead to quantum
mechanics,
which Einstein had a hand in,
as well.
Okay, so, now let me move on to
general relativity.
That's a good moment to make
this transition.
So, general relativity,
known as GR,
for short, is now a theory of
gravity.
So, the part of Newtonian
physics that is overthrown,
or encompassed,
as I was saying,
by special relativity,
are the Laws of Motion.
Now, general relativity has the
law--those same laws of motion,
but also has embedded in it a
theory of gravity,
which is fundamentally
different from the way Newton
thought about gravity.
So, Newtonian gravity is
thought of as a force.
It's a particular force.
It's the force of gravity.
There's a little equation,
the force of gravity is equal
to the gravitational constant,
G, times the mass of one
object, times the mass of the
other object,
divided by the distance between
them squared.
And the odd thing--and this was
sort of the starting point of
Einstein's thought.
The odd thing is these masses.
And because--remember,
somebody asked me last time,
what is mass?
And I gave you a whole thing
about the inertial mass.
How much it resists being
pushed.
And that comes about from
F = ma. And so,
the kind of mass that I defined
last time is the inertial
mass--how much it resists being
pushed.
And so, conceptually--the mass
that's in Newton's equations of
gravity--conceptually,
that's a different kind of
mass.
It doesn't have to be the same
number.
This is gravitational mass,
because it's defined
differently.
It's defined not by how much an
object resists being pushed by a
force--any force,
but by how much the object
creates a particular kind of
force.
So, in this,
it's how much it resists
forces.
In this, it's how much the
force is created.
And these are conceptually
different things.
It turns out that to the best
experimental evidence that you
can muster, which by now is
many,
many decimal places,
these two kinds of mass are
exactly the same.
This has an experimental
consequence that was known
already to Galileo in the
seventeenth century.
Look what happened.
Supposing M_1
is the Earth,
and M_2 is
some object that you're dropping
from a high tower.
So, the story is,
Galileo goes to the top of the
Tower of Pisa.
He drops a cannonball,
or something,
and watches it fall.
Then what happens?
You substitute
F_gravity into
the equation of motion.
And what do you get?
So, you're using a particular
kind of force.
So, you get GM of the
object, M of the Earth,
divided by distance squared,
where the distance is the
distance between the centers of
the objects--so,
this is basically the distance
to the center of the Earth--is
equal to the mass of the object,
times its acceleration.
And, look.
If this mass is the same as
that mass, they cancel.
What does that mean?
So, you can do this.
It means the motion,
the acceleration of the object,
doesn't depend on its mass.
The acceleration of the object
will be the same for any object
because, if it has greater
inertia,
it also generates,
by exactly a proportional
amount, a greater force.
And so, everything falls from
the tower at the same rate.
And that's what Galileo did.
He brought up a cannonball,
and a wooden ball,
and a whole bunch of other
objects, dropped them,
and discovered that the Greeks
had been wrong.
The Greeks imagined the heavier
the thing is,
the fast it falls.
But the only reason you think
that is because of dropping
things like feathers,
which do fall kind of slowly
and erratically.
That has nothing to do with
gravity.
That's air pressure, right?
And so, if you drop things that
are heavy enough so that air
pressure isn't important,
they fall at the same rate.
So, that is the experiment that
proves that gravitational mass
is the same as inertial mass.
All other forces don't have
this consequence.
There is, for example--well,
let me not draw on the corner
here.
I'll be just like the cranks.
You know, I'll start drawing
all the way around the edge of
the thing, here.
So, let us go on.
Let's see.
There is, for example,
electrical force,
which has a very similar kind
of equation.
That's a constant,
times the charge of one object,
times the charge of another
object, divided by the distance
between them squared.
That looks almost identical to
what the gravitational force
looks like.
But, because the charge of an
object isn't equal to its mass,
different objects respond
differently to--when put
in--when an electric force is
exerted on them.
If you compare a proton,
which is a mass of subatomic
particle of charge one,
with a positron,
which is a low-mass particle of
charge one.
And you put the same amount of
force on them,
the positron will move much
more, because it has so much
less mass.
And so, different objects
respond in different ways to all
forces except gravity.
So, the unusual thing about
gravity--so, gravity is weird,
because the gravitational mass
turns out to be exactly equal,
at least, to the best possible
measurements,
to the inertial mass.
And there's no excuse within
Newtonian theory to explain why
that might be,
and why all objects
move--therefore,
move the same when put in a
gravitational field.
Okay, so, this bugged Einstein.
This is the kind of thing that
bothered him.
And so, to explain this and
other related,
sort of conceptual issues,
he promulgated a completely
different theory--namely--so.
Einstein says--okay.
So, gravity,
Einstein says,
is not a force.
That's not the right way to
think about it.
And so, what--how does this
work, then?
All right, so point one.
Objects move in a straight
line, when they are not in a
straight line,
in the absence of a force.
This is Newton's first law,
or something.
If you're moving at a constant
velocity, you will continue
moving in the same direction,
at the same speed,
unless something happens;
like, a force is applied to you.
If gravity isn't a force,
that should still be true.
Objects are moving in straight
lines all the time,
whether there's a
gravita--whether there's gravity
around or not.
That seems very odd,
because we know perfectly well
that things--that when you have
a gravitational force,
and you're in an orbit,
you go around in a circle,
not in a straight line at all.
So, how does Einstein reconcile
this with reality?
And that's part two of the
theory.
Part two of the theory is that
the presence of mass--inertial
mass, now--creates curvature in
space-time, space and time.
Now, how does that help?
That helps because you have to
then go back and think:
what do you mean by going in a
straight line if you're in a
curved space?
I'll give you some examples of
this that you can see in a
minute.
What you mean by a straight
line is the shortest distance
between two points.
Now, we know from
experience--or many of us know
from experience--that on a
curved spaced the shortest
difference between two points is
not exactly what you would
expect it to be.
Has anyone flown on an airplane
from here to Asia,
for example?
Fly from New York to Beijing.
So, let's make a map,
a flat map.
So, here's a flat space--north,
east, west, south.
Here's New York.
Here's Beijing.
And you might imagine,
if things were flat,
that the way you would get--and
the quickest way that the
airlines would save money,
you know, because they
don't--is that they would fly
directly east.
Because it's more or less at
the same latitude,
New York and Beijing.
But that isn't what happens.
That isn't what happens at all.
What you do,
if you fly that route,
or if you go the other way to
Europe, wherever it is that
you're going is,
you fly this way.
You go way up north.
You look down halfway through,
there's the Artic.
Why do you do that?
It's because the Earth isn't
flat.
The Earth is a sphere.
And so, what it really looks
like is this.
Here's the Earth.
Here's New York.
Here's Beijing,
and you fly this way,
because that's the shortest
distance across a--the surface
of the sphere,
between two points.
I have a sphere somewhere.
Let's see, here's a sphere
[holds up a basketball].
And this line here--think of
this as the equator.
And if you go from here to
here, it would be the shortest
distance between the two
points--would be to go right
across the equator.
But we're not going on the
equator.
We're in the northern
hemisphere.
So now, I'm going to tip this
upward so that these two things
are both in the northern
hemisphere.
And now this line goes up and
across.
And if I tip it all the way up,
so that you would be dealing
with two cities on the opposite
side of the world,
as New York and Beijing,
close enough,
it goes--the closest line
between them doesn't go around
this way,
it goes straight up over the
top.
So, if you project that onto a
flat map, it looks like this.
But in fact,
on a sphere,
on the surface of a sphere,
that is the shortest distance
between those two points.
It's the exact same distance as
it would be in the equator.
You just tip the thing up,
and it's clear that this is the
long way around.
So, if you have a curved space
and you're trying to get,
in the shortest way,
from one point to another,
and you don't know you're on a
curved space,
you interpret it as a flat
space,
then you will interpret the
path that you take as curved.
And so, Einstein's statement is
that the presence of mass
doesn't exert a gravitational
force.
That's the wrong way to think
about it.
What it does is,
it creates a curvature in the
space-time.
And so, then,
objects traveling from one
place to another move in
straight lines,
defined as the shortest
distance between those two
points.
But if we're not taking the
curvature into account,
it looks like it's going around
in circles.
All right.
Tough concept.
So, let's demonstrate this.
The sheet is supposed to
represent space-time.
Space-time is--and now,
I've got to explain that,
right?
So, what is space time?
Because it's space-time that's
doing the curving.
It's--you can think of it as a
four-dimensional coordinate
system, where the four
dimensions are the three
familiar spatial dimensions,
X, Y, Z,
and T for time.
And you can understand where
any given event,
where an event is something
that happens,
can be identified with four
numbers.
It's spatial position--that's
three numbers,
and the time at which it
occurs.
Now, in order to get these
things into the same units,
you have to actually represent
this as the speed of light times
time,
because that--multiplying by
the speed of light turns time
units into space units,
because this is miles per hour,
or space per time.
So, one year of time is the
equivalent of one light-year of
distance.
That's how it converts.
And so, one interesting
thing--and, of course,
the sheet, there,
was a two-dimensional space,
and only had X and
Y that could identify any
point on the sheet.
So, the metaphor is to use two
spatial dimensions to represent
what is actually a
four--conceptually,
a four-dimensional space.
That's why it's a metaphor and
not something real.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
yes.
Absolutely correct.
Does gravity bend time, too?
It has an effect on time
similar to time dilation when
you're going really fast.
If you get really close to a
black hole, your clocks will
slow down.
Yeah, yes?
Student: Why is that?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Why is that?
Let me--next time,
I'll write down the
Schwarzschild metric,
and I'll try and answer that
question.
Let me go on,
here, for a minute,
and point out an important
thing about this agreement,
here, which is--that means the
Earth, in its motion,
for example,
in one year--the time
coordinate moves one light-year,
which is 10^(16) meters.
The space coordinate moves 2π
times the semi-major axis,
which is 1 Astronomical Unit.
That's 2π times 1.5 times
10^(11) meters.
That's something like 10^(12)
meters.
So, the Earth moves 10,000
times further in time than it
moves in space in a year.
And that means that the Earth's
motion in space-time is almost
precisely a straight line,
going straight forward in time.
So, here's time.
Here's, I don't know,
the X-axis.
And you could imagine that as
time goes on,
the Earth, you know,
moves around the Sun.
So its X-axis --so its
X-coordinate goes back
and back--back and forth.
Here's the Sun,
which, you know,
wiggles a little bit,
much less than the Earth,
as we discussed.
But this picture,
here, is inaccurate,
because in fact this distance
here, which is half a year,
is 10,000 times longer than
this distance here,
which is half an orbit.
And so--and so,
in fact, the Earth's motion is
represented by something that's
almost exactly a straight
line--so much so that I couldn't
possibly draw the wiggle in a
way that you could see it.
So, here's the Earth going
forward in time.
And the wiggle is really small.
That's not surprising,
because the gravitational force
of the Sun is small enough so
that the Earth's orbit is
correctly described by Newtonian
physics.
And so, this is one of those
situations where you have a
Newtonian physics in relatively
low gravitational fields.
And as the gravitational fields
get stronger,
weird relativistic effects kick
in.
But that doesn't happen for the
Earth.
So there's--the number is this.
Schwarzschild radius divided by
distance, is the measure of how
relativistic an orbit is.
And if this number is small,
then you get correct answers
from the Newtonian theory.
And we can work it out.
The Schwarzschild radius of the
Sun, 3 x 10^(3) meters.
The distance from the Earth to
the Sun, 1.5 x 10^(11) meters.
That's 2 x 10^(-8) and that's a
small number.
So, Earth works fine in a
Newtonian sense.
Yes?
Student: Is that
R the radius of the orbit
or the radius of the [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: That is the distance
of the moving object from the
center of the gravitating thing
that's making the curvature
happen.
Yeah.
So, yes is the answer.
It's the radius of the orbit.
Yes?
Student: Was the theory
of general relativity a theory
that was just promulgated,
or does it actually have
equations associated with it?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh yes.
Does it have equations
associated with it?
You bet.
You don't want to see them.
There's a branch of mathematics
called differential geometry,
because--what happens is,
this curvature stuff is all
geometry.
And the problem is that the
further away you get from an
object, the less the space is
curved.
So, the amount on the sphere,
on the surface of the
sphere--it's curved the same way
everywhere.
So, the equations that describe
the curvature are the same at
any point on a sphere.
But you can imagine something
that starts out with strong
curvature and tails off.
And then the amount of
curvature at any given point is
different from any other point.
So, you have to describe it
with a differential amount of
curvature, and then integrate
over the path that things take.
This gets heinous,
and we're not going to go
there.
But I will show you,
next time, some specific
examples of some of these
equations,
because it'll help explain
things like why space and time
are reversed inside an event
horizon and stuff.
But, you bet,
there's a whole mathematical
theory.
In fact, Einstein was not the
world's greatest mathematician
and it took him until 1917 to
get all this worked out.
He had to go and get himself
some math tutoring at the
University of Göttingen and--so
that he could understand the
geometric properties.
So, yeah, there's a big
mathematical theory behind it.
Yes?
Student: So,
if gravity is not a force,
how can you use F = ma?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: F = ma is a
general equation of motion.
It doesn't have to be the force
of gravity.
There are many other forces in
the world.
Student: But when you're
setting F = ma to
GMM or [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Right,
so, that's the Newtonian idea,
that you set F = ma
equal to GMM over
D^(2).
And the thing that prompted
Einstein's thought was the fact
that the two different kinds of
masses on each side of the
equation turned out to be equal.
And you can see why this
explains that.
Because, if what's happening is
that you curve space,
and then things follow a
trajectory dictated by the
curvature of that space,
then it makes perfect sense
that all objects follow the same
trajectory, regardless of their
mass.
Because they're not actually
being forced to move anywhere.
They're just going in straight
lines, and straight lines are
the same no matter what your
mass is.
And so, that's why this kind of
curvature provides an
explanation for what,
in the Newtonian approximation,
is the equality of the inertial
and the gravitational mass.
How we doing?
Oh, we've got some more time,
good.
Go ahead.
Student: Would a clock
really slow down as it moved
towards the [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah.
Student: [inaudible]
would you have a perception of
[inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Well,
of course, you are a clock,
right?
You're--no, you wouldn't notice.
But what would happen is this.
Supposing you're falling into a
black hole, or something.
You look at your clock.
You feel your pulse, you know.
Your pulse measured by your
clock has not changed.
But you look back out into the
world that is distant from the
black hole, and things are
moving really fast out there.
And so, if you had two
synchronized,
identical clocks at the start
of your voyage,
and you keep an eye on what's
happening out here,
you will discover that,
all of a sudden,
it looks like your clock is
moving slow.
And, all of a sudden,
you know, people are aging and
dying back on Earth,
while, you know,
it's only been a week in your
perception.
And so, turn it around.
You're sitting on Earth
watching your friend fall
through--fall into a black hole.
And it looks like he's slowing
down, and slowing down,
and slowing down and maybe--and
never really quite gets to the
event horizon,
even in an infinite amount of
time.
But the perception of the
person falling through is that
they just fall through.
It's just, the whole Universe
is evolved in the time that
they've done it.
So, it's one of these weird
things where time turns out--how
fast time passes turns out to be
a property of who's doing the
measuring.
Very strange concept,
and very counterintuitive to
the way we live our life.
Because we all think--because
we live in low gravitational
fields at low speeds,
we think time is an absolute
thing that ticks onward for
everybody in the same way,
but it turns out it isn't true.
Yes?
And again, I'll show you an
equation that--actually,
this is much easier to deal
with in equations than it is
conceptually,
and I'll show you an equation
next time which may help.
Student: Can you explain
about the names behind the two
theories of relativity?
I mean, it doesn't seem like
the general theory is a
generalization of the special
theory.
Professor Charles
Bailyn: It actually is,
because it incorporates aspects
of the special theory.
And it's a generalization in
terms of what's called the
metric.
The metric is the mathematical
formula that describes the
curvature.
And the special theory of
relativity is the special case
where the metric is flat.
And then, the reason general
relativity is a generalization
is because it allows other--many
other kinds of metrics.
Or, at least,
that's one way of thinking
about it.
Yes sir.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah well I--too
small for me to draw.
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: The wiggle is from
the motion of the Earth around
the Sun.
And it's caused by--the mass of
the Sun warps the space--
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
It's just--all I meant in the
second one--sorry,
I didn't explain this clearly.
All I meant in the second one
was that this one is inaccurate
in terms of scale.
Student: Okay, oh I see.
Professor Charles
Bailyn: And that the scale,
the true scale,
is such that this length ought
to be 10,000 times longer than
that.
And under those circumstances
you'd never be able to see it.
That's all I meant by that.
Yeah?
Student: What happens to
time when you're caught
traveling--you mentioned this,
but what happens to time when
you're traveling close to the
speed of light?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Slows down yeah.
Yes?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
how does, how does this work?
Right.
We are, you know--you can
explain the motion of the Earth
in terms of these so-called
space-time diagrams,
where one--you take the
four-dimensional thing.
You project it onto two
dimensions.
You can write a space-time
diagram for yourself,
and you can explain all of the
motion and all of the things
that happen by such a curved
thing.
So, what happens if you jump,
for example?
In the Newtonian theory,
you jump, you ought to keep
going straight up,
except that there is a force,
which pulls you back down.
So, that we understand.
What happens--how is that
explained in general relativity?
You jump and you go in a
straight line,
but the straight line is
through a curved space--curved
because of the presence of the
Earth.
And so, it turns out that the
straight line looks like this.
It goes up and comes back down
again, in just the same way that
the straight line between New
York and Beijing goes over the
North Pole.
It goes up and comes back down
again, because space-time is
curved due to the gravity of the
Earth.
So, something that we perceive
to be a curved
trajectory--jumping up,
falling back down--if you
project it into space-time,
is actually the closest
distance between two events.
So, there's two alternative
explanations of these things.
In the situation where you're
nowhere near a black hole,
it turns out that,
mathematically,
they're exactly equivalent.
If they're exactly equivalent,
it's much easier to calculate
the Newtonian way,
and much easier to think about
it.
So, until you get into a
situation where the
Schwarzschild radius is
comparable to the distances
involved,
you're way better off thinking
Newtonian, because we're just
better at it.
Yes?
Student: I understand
that in order to get units that
you can line up in any way,
uniquely, you need to multiply
time by a velocity.
But I'm a little confused
about--I mean I know that
c is this really
important number-- Professor
Charles Bailyn: Yeah.
Student: - but if the
only reason why the wiggles in
the graph of motion are really
tiny is because c is so
enormous.
I mean - Professor Charles
Bailyn: Couldn't you pick
another velocity?
Student: Right.
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yeah.
Student: What makes that
an accurate scaling?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Okay,
so, the reason that's an
accurate scaling is,
one of the things that comes
out of the theory of relativity
is that there is a natural unit.
There's a natural set of units.
And the natural set of units
are the units in which these
crucial constants,
of which c is one and
G is another,
and H--the Planck
constant,
which governs quantum
mechanics, are all equal to one.
And that turns--those are
called Planck units,
and they have--and the
conversion between different
kinds of energy,
mass to energy,
things like that,
all work out as equalities in
the particular set of units,
where all those constants come
out to be one.
So, there is a reason why that
particular velocity is chosen,
and it's not surprising,
if you had to pick a velocity,
that you would end up with the
speed of light,
which has this sort of profound
importance.
Okay, we'll continue next time.